oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play electronic
super joy I'm still kind of burnt out
from yesterday's 12-hour livestream
which went on for a long long time so uh
but the show must go on I'm not gonna
miss a single day after loading but when
I saw this game I knew that I had to
play and when I opened this game I
really knew that I had to play because
it's this music was freaking awesome so
let's get into it oh man it's a
platformer game if you didn't know and
from what I saw in the trailer yeah may
cause seizures there's a lot of bright
lights in this one motion sickness tons
of crude language pixelated violence and
murder sexual content blasphemy this is
my kind of game this is the best game
ever
alright I haven't even played it again I
know it's the best game ever oh the
music's going on oh you lost an arm oh
that's a shame
in the disco Wars of 15 15 you lost an
eye in the war of rock and roll you lost
both legs defeating DJ deadly skills and
you lost your entire butt not my butt to
an evil wizard damn him
I'll get my butt back this is the story
of her quest to get to get revenge for
your butt Oh joyous day Callooh Callay
anyway this is an indie game with what I
saw oh yes I think I just got a
checkpoint welcome
we've been waiting like four
all right then
oh yeah I think that's what it meant by
the sexual content ah there we go
ah well you know I never made any claims
to be a good gamer actually got to turn
the volume down because it's like
blowing out my ear but I'm just really
cool music you know what I mean I have
got to be able to hear myself talk ah
screwattack's you like the music better
than the sound of my own voice bouncing
is fun we like you you're groovy but
I've lost my butt arms and legs how can
you like me jump and press X what whoa
notlikethis checkpoints wait can you
hear that oh no I think he's mad again
you should go please go bye okay so I
don't know what the deal is but there's
like 48 different levels dude dude what
dude have you seen my butt nice day nice
day to find my butt guys have you seen
my butt looks like a butt it's a little
but like oh yeah here it comes my butt
goodbye pot over there
sorry I just had to dance to the music
for a bit there they told me to dance so
I'm gonna dance whenever I damn well
please I don't ever I don't have a butt
to shake anymore on the dance floor but
if any of you guys meet me in public in
like a club or something cuz I go to
those all the time it'll see me shaking
my booty working on the dancefloor
and then everybody will run away and
then knowing I'll never be welcome in
that club ever again warning this game
is apparently not for kids in all its
pixelated
it's not just ladies involved in here oh
you touch my tralala
lying yep yep yep oh come on I can't
suck this bad this is absolutely
impossible for me to be this bad so says
me but apparently that's just a lie
because I end this bad because it's
markiplier we're talking about here not
known for my skill in gaming I like it
when the guy does it better that's just
my personal preference
he's more breadth indeed years so what's
the difference between the arrows and
the stars that I jump off to
stylistically I have no idea end of
level I'm gonna win there we go
the walls are all sticky why why are the
walls sticky guys in my hair why are the
walls sticky it doesn't make any sense
hey guys have you seen my but I'm
looking for my but it's about yea big it
looks like a but have you seen it have
you seen a but it's got two cheeks on it
big point anybody it's been known to
twerk randomly you seen a butt hey sir
with the sign don't go down there man
where don't go down where put down there
wait down below me how am I supposed to
jump is why put down there we okay I
guess I'm here I think Judy I want that
star please oh yeah got it okay good oh
yeah oh how many people they got into
the studio just to say
and the microphone just like randomly at
lengths just go into the city like they
shove a microphone in front of the face
and though hey say oh yeah and the most
sexy way possible in Emily why why would
I say them oh yeah just do it man come
on it's for a pixelated platformer game
they're like wha-what well that doesn't
make any sense guy what do you need them
for the Josh I out yeah and they're like
oh yeah yeah little did anyone know I
actually did all the voices for the oh
yes you probably didn't know that but
I'm telling you now just gotta stop the
missiles out when you get to me yeah I
prefer the male voices just that's a
personal preference hey have you seen my
put are those missiles homing in on my
butt well they're not here so they
shouldn't be homing in on me how am i
jumping and walking if I lost both my
legs and an arm and my boy what muscles
are pretty integral no you son of a but
yeah let's see if we can get out of your
boob there we go alright that's much
better
I still haven't seen where the blasphemy
comes in oh yes oh you'll touch my
tralala you know i reference that a few
times i don't know if anyone actually
remembers what that's from
or i've seen that i reference a lot of
internet 2.0 stuff there's a number that
wampa what
what what whoa whoa whoa you can't just
lower gravity like that all of a sudden
that looks like a beam of death what
with all the mess house yeah that wasn't
wasn't even to know yeah those just oh
yes wait a minute I don't think this
woman oh I had it I was on a roll oh
yeah wait for it wait for it it's gonna
be great
ah you didn't tell me I couldn't touch
that I'll touch whatever the hell I want
to touch because apparently this this
game is not for kitties no I didn't even
jump what kind of douche yeah whatever
you know what ah stop being angry is
just cuz the soundtrack is so awesome in
this game yeah this is like you know I
like I like elemental soundtrack it's so
touching this one
seriously where does the blast when you
come in that one I want some blasphemy
up in my life
don't waste time finding my butt stop
floating around stop on those missiles
why yeah oh you'd stop you made me stop
right into the dirt yeah sheesh about
how Oh jump right into it I am so stop
agreeing that I'm so awful game I don't
need your sass right now I'm trying to
beat this
don't waste time here ladies are you
ladies I have no idea if you like to
ladies okay just one I can deal with
just one I think probably not
oh I'm causing them to self-destruct
that's so sad for them who do know you
don't
all these are sticky balls Oh Oh God oh
they're so disgusting
oh okay what am I doing here that
doesn't even make any sense
I want that whatever I don't want it I
don't want it that badly yeah maybe I
want it too late now I guess I don't
want it that badly so what am I suppose
to do about all these missiles here yeah
besides stomp on them
yay lava lower can I find my butt now
I'd really like to find my ball I would
just really appreciate the location of
all that was cheap come on come on come
on what you got whoa
there no no no no no that did not work
Oh at least I dodged those missiles
they're not bothering me anymore
chip well this is a game that is going
awry come on help me find my boy
gosh dang you guys aren't helping me
find my but need to find my but I
brought it stomp on your head
I'm trying to stop I can't coordinate
without my but I'm not good at this stop
on this even Mario couldn't stop on the
goomahs without his giant but never one
knows it Mario at them biggest butt of
them all now how about I not aim for the
arrow at all how about I do that Luigi
was never I stopped right on him you
can't tell me I didn't you can't tell me
I stopped saying oh yeah you're just
mocking me oh I'm gonna get you you son
of a gun you stupid son of a monkey
another piece of bollocks
that's that's curse word in an England
land a mother humper
no one's gonna let me well my but you
won't like me when I'm but let's go girl
yeah yeah there we go okay yeah now you
can say oh yeah when I get some
semblance I stop right into the
afterlife oh yeah yes indeed madam this
is celebration indeed I'm so happy
yeah boy miss me
Oh what's that you're trying to get me
you can't you're what seeking missiles
but I have no blood so get out of here
yeah hello ladies if you are lady I have
no idea
well that was dumb the Pope has gone
insane is this where the blasphemy comes
in well I can't do much about the Pope
because I can't even get over to you
there we go the Pope has gone insane why
how or been mind control anyway he wants
to kill you that's that's good
I think guess you'll have to murder him
oh well well bears the blasphemy
I gotta go murder the Pope come on I'm
gonna I'm gonna throw someone down a
well
that's what I'm gonna have to do I'm
gonna throw someone oh well that's just
all there is to it
there we go hi mr. Pope are you the Pope
you got a pope hat howdy I'm the Pope
good to see you all right knowing you
good and I'm gonna [ __ ] you up yeah all
right pop-tastic well bring it on Pope's
Meister your silly hat can't stop me now
yep nope just cuz I got no arms and legs
what was that your popemobile you're
flying popemobile hey puppy come back
here puppy come back whoa I'm not wait
what if whoa what you know why don't I
take this giant beam that responds me
and use it to try to kill some enemies
obey God boy yo I'm pretty cross right
now wow that's hilarious puns man puns
are the funniest form of humor obviously
yeah oh come on oh no you suck hope I
hate you oh come up or not I'm gonna run
away fall down a hole because somebody
harmful ants you Mother Hubbard just
getting the whole or get out of a hole
that's what I meant
you guys know what I meant shout out Oh
Oh your cross right now oh no I get it
you're very funny you're funnier than I
am for damn sure
Oh what how was that you suck you suck
you suck I don't suck hey don't blame me
I don't have a button come on guys just
deal with me for a second here I'm
trying to do this but list well I
thought I was dead that's why I stopped
trying you son of a son of a [ __ ] I'm
not you're you're mad really pump you're
mad you should see me you should see me
right now
I've lost my butt I've lost my arms and
legs I have nothing I can do nothing and
I'm going to try to kill the Pope hi I
am sweating I'm very angry I do not need
this kind of stress in my life right now
you son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm going to kill you I'm going to
kill you I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna
kill you I'm not even talking about the
Pope anymore I'm talking about my
character I'm gonna kill him oh no no no
no no no give me a goddamn check right
ah you man check Mike no no no not this
time
whoa not this time oh you touch my
tralala no no now
I'm done I'm not even gonna kill the
bump no yeah yeah yeah whoo you screw
you give me some music
give me a I'm tired music whatever done
messed up my webcam done done I'm done
I'm done I meant I wanted this game to
relax me so we're just gonna have a
dance party for the rest of this we're
just gonna dance